[Musique]
je suis philosophe donc j'ai su curieuse
ou alors je suis curieuse donc je suis
philosophe je crois que c'est plutôt ça
je crois que c'est parce que l'on est
curieux qu'on est philosophe philosophes
etc ont parfois parce que la curiosité
et furieusement et c'est ça qu'est née
ma curiosité aujourd'hui je suis
curieuse de la curiosité et du coup pour
tenter de satisfaire cette curiosité
j'ai commencé par faire quelque chose de
tout simple
j'ai ouvert un dictionnaire ses fameux
carnets référentiels et dans ce cadre m
j'ai trouvé une définition disons depuis
la première mot féminin qui qualifie
c'est une qualité celle de désirez
connaître
du coup je me dis que c'est plutôt
gratifiant
curieuse et puis en deuxième définition
vais trouver l'un des mots féminins
c'est vrai on lui attribue souvent
curieusement d'ailleurs à savoir ce
désir indiscret de savoir alors on
pourrait en rester à ce carnet
personnellement je ne suis pas
satisfaite
ma curiosité n'est pas d'ici là ça y est
j'ai fait le même pari gourou et du coup
je vous propose plutôt de mettre ce
carnet de côté et d'essayer d'incarner
la curiosité de voir comment elle se
manifeste au la queue dans un manifeste
de voir concrètement ce qu'on veut en
dire et tout d'abord j'ai bronze d'éveil
ensemble notre curiosité en se demandant
en se demandant justement s'intéressant
au désir d'un discret de savoir je suis
curieuse et j'aime avoir le désir de
connaître ou d'en connaître davantage
sur ce désir indiscret de savoir le
désir indiscrètes ça
qui d'entre vous n'a jamais eu envie de
savoir ce qu'elle pense dépenses
l'envers d'une récompense qui n'a jamais
eu envie de savoir d'en savoir plus sur
la vie des gens la vie liesse et la vie
des gens qui nagent à lui cette
tentation impudique
lorsqu'il passe est revenu que la une de
pudique voici autres magazines tout le
monde
alors certains pourraient peut-être
choisir mais ça la regarde elle se mêle
de ses affaires c'est pas ces zones où
j'ai pris part et vous nous auriez pas
me dire ça m'arrange du coup pas trop
d'une manière générale la démarche ici
beaucoup moins ludique que philosophique
du moins dans sa forme alors formules
ont tout d'abord un premier bon ça nous
sommes tous naturellement vous et moi et
les curieux on a ce désir discret de
savoir mais à moins d'être con ou un
brin enfantin contre les conventions on
va canaliser tout ça on va justement
essayer de pas se poser des questions on
évite des pieds son voisin de flou et
mon portable son conjoint ou d'aller
regarder journal intime de son enfant
ce qu'analysent 11 disciplines parce que
d'une c'est maladroit et en plus de ça
ce serait malsain et on voit
effectivement que dans la vie d'une
parce qu'on grandit de deux parce qu'on
ne vit en communauté avec d'autres
personnes et des règles à respecter
et bien ce désir premier à être
disciplinés et vaut mieux sinon vous
risqueriez de passer pour quelqu'un de
curieux sens de bizarre cette foire est
d'être rejeté
et quelle s premier lieu qui accommodent
cette curiosité enfin comme à l'école
l'école c'est ce premier lieu
effectivement ou et bien le l'impatience
de savoir que vous aimez quand vous êtes
enfant est bien à se cultiver en désir
de connaître ça au jour la première
définition ce désir de connaître
un désir de connaître discipline et
rappelez vous allez d'école en vous
asseoir sur une chaise en dispense des
cours donc vous voyez vous la plupart
disent penser un petit peu et on vous a
guéri différentes choses on forge votre
curiosité autant qu'on la force
on vous donne quantité de choses à
savoir si on m'aime vraiment savoir
pourquoi il ya la question de l'utilité
dispose faute d'expérience et d'intérêt
qu'il n'a jamais ressenti ce est frustré
de cette accumulation le labeur de
l'apprentissage par coeur la prescrivent
d'annotations alors même mais
rappelez-vous ça alors même que c'est
une période où ces veilles ici et vous
fait la cour quelque chose souvent comme
vous êtes en cours à savoir la cour la
cour que vous observez du coin de l'oeil
qui elle vous rappelle justement
différentes choses et effectivement
quand on est enfant on est naturellement
portés par cet élan on observe le monde
et montaigne était assez orient sur ça
puisqu'ils nous rappelait que le but
même de l'instruction d'un enfant c'est
celui de contribuer à ces délais d'une
curiosité qui la baule est joyeuse et je
m'entendrai la formule de daniel pennac
que j'aime beaucoup dans son ouvrage
qu'ils avaient comme un roman qui me dit
on ne force pas une curiste et on
l'éveil en effectivement l'école
aujourd'hui mais il semble qu'elle
cultive davantage une curiosité qui est
plutôt en kiosque que joyeuse curiosité
joyeuse qui serait celle de
l'observation du questionnement la
curiosité
monsieur c'est celle de l'application
plutôt que de l'implication de
l'apprentissage par coeur sans vraiment
vous encourager en mettant d'ailleurs du
coeur du coeur à l'ouvragé dans tout
cela c'est aussi dans la réponse les
réponses pour vous les sabots menèrent
plutôt que les questions ou l'art du
questionnement c'est aussi ce savoir
fonctionnel on apprend pour utiliser
pour l'utiliser a ajouté dans sa copie
le ressortir se spécialiser mon but d'un
métier on apprend pour apprendre et pour
utiliser ces savoirs alors c'est vrai
effectivement que ensuite on se dit que
ce qu'on en retient parce que après
l'école via l'école de la vie et l'école
de la ligue en prison n'est retenu des
leçons
ce qui est dommage effectivement des
danses et d'apprentissage pour savoir
quand est-ce vraiment
retenu des choses et c'est ça on va
pouvoir faire perdurer dans cette école
de la vie alors je dirai tout d'abord
que l'école c'est un des premiers
sentiers qui nous amène à cette école de
la vie et malheureusement alors si le
parcours et le sentier est de combien
mais étant parfois il est peut-être trop
stricte
trois cas nick peu autonomisant et du
coup peu professionnalisé mais je dis
quand même pour ma part merci à l'école
puisqu'elle a permis une tare on va
rencontrer la philosophie mais je les
rencontre et quand même et cette
philosophie c'est quoi ces canards
questionnement donc aujourd'hui c'est
grâce à l'école que je me permets de la
critique et puisque l on a donné les
moyens et l'opportunité de voir la
rencontre
ce qui m'intéresse par la suite c'est
cette école de la vie effectivement on
va enlever on voir où va aller juste
après ça y est le constat que je fais
tout ça c'est intéressant de voir entre
elles on est devenus mans est en fait
dans l'école jolivent redevient les
enfants c'est assez paradoxal
j'avais envie d'essayer de devoir se
lavent redevient des enfants parce que
même si le désir de connaître fille pour
nous parce intention était justement de
savoir on aidé un patient
des curieux qu'un passion on a quitté
les bancs de la vie d'école pour prendre
les bancs ou pour aller justement en
classe dans la classe du monde
professionnel et on se rend compte que
être un élève discipliné
en tout cas ça va pas suffire ça peut
pas suffire ce qu'on a appris ne suffira
pas vraiment pourquoi parce que la vie
elle est indiscipliné des choses bougent
les choses changent et que travailler ne
peut pas se résumer à appliquer ce qu'on
a vu c'est aussi accueillir cette
indiscipline et donc être forcément sur
le qui vive et la vie nous rabaisse la
ville de nous rappeler avril vous
rappelle à l'ordre
plutôt désordre observons donc le monde
dans lequel nous sommes
c'est le désordre qu'il y a toute cette
activité c'est un monde qui bouge et qui
bouge comme je les conteste ip ryan
contexte hyper complexe
tout le monde ya un monde où des moyens
de communication les connaissances le
savoir les techniques évoluent ce qu'on
apprend devient rapidement obsolète
du coup ça veut dire quoi que d'une ça
presse notre curiosité wallet
et ça stresse de curiosité la visite
éclair qui d'abord d'ailleurs un rapport
et un comportement vis-à-vis de
l'inconnu c'est cette curieuse ses
vis-à-vis d'un inconnu dans un monde où
tout change et bouger la commune est
parti bien vieille dame et crise et
l'avenir avec du monde
du coup vous êtes constamment au qe2
idée ya une inconnue et la curiosité
ceci ceux qui s'énervent et bien d'une
instance d'une insatisfaction si vous
êtes curieux c'est qu'il vous manque
quelque chose dans une société où on n'a
jamais autant de possibles de désir qui
s'offre à nous les banques sont partis
plus vous allez possibilité que vous
manquez potentiellement de choses
les régulateurs j'ai envie d'un nouveau
boulot j'ai envie de changer de femme
les nouvelles maîtresses chez mme david
accord avec les colons mais vous voyez
au final on est dans cette impatience la
lui désire s impatientent outrepassant
même les limites de l'utilité connaître
pourquoi pourquoi cela vient presque 20
ans et l'âge boutique parce qu elle qui
le dit la curiosité n'est que vanité
lorsqu'elle est immodéré lorsqu'elle
éthique modéré je rajouterais
lorsqu'elle est hyper fonctionnel hyper
fonctionnel pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est le désir de
connaître davantage pour en tirer
avantage
mais pour 7 km à 7,4 importante
du coup il ya une indiscipline des
grands aux caprices d'enfant et un
sublime grandissant un spin grandissant
parce que la curiosité nous perd perte
de sens
obsolescence obsolète sans
nécessairement et dans tout ça bien la
question j'ai envie de vous poser c'est
les écoliers de léry que nous sommes
n'aurait-il retenu pour le son de
l'école que l'idée que le savoir est
fonctionnel or il n'ya pas que des
sciences à l'école ya l'essence même de
l'école l'essence de l'école c'est la
curiosité c'est désir de connaître le
désir de connaître ou pour y mettre du
sens amour de la connaissance
et c'est là que j'arrive à mon troisième
fois le désir de connaître j'aime jouer
sur les mots
c'est un mot quand même une invitation
c'est à dire le désir de connaître pour
naître avec ce programme à leytron qu'on
essaye de connaître il ya quelque chose
qui se passe c'est pas se connaître pour
l'utiliser c'est le connaît pour s'en
trouvait aussi changé grandit pas que
mon livre dans l'espace ça c'est une
montagne de possible que nous avons
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de terminer avec
montagne mountain qui lui s'essayer dans
ses essais brillamment à la curiosité
curiosité joyeuse et judicieuse pour
justement observé le temps dans lequel
il était et les troubles civils de
l'époque qui le concerne et alors qu'est
ce qu'il faisait a dit que ces
curiosités
elle avait un côté joli et agréable
parce qu'elle nous invitait tous à voir
plus loin que le bout de notre nez du
mal à considérer le monde comme une
expérience de jugement et elle prendre
comme une matière d'apprentissage pas à
la face on voit la leçon pour nous dire
de ce qu'il appelait déjà à l'époque les
boiteux les boîtes de céder ce qui
justement n'apprennent pour trouver les
causes
l'aspect scientifique pour trouver des
réponses si je fais une analogie les
boiteux que nous pouvions être
aujourd'hui ce serait lui avait
personnellement à ses hommes et des
femmes de l'école david qui cherchent
aujourd'hui des réponses des résultats
des soutiens belles images pour
comprendre les rives du choses comme si
le sens acheté en barre plutôt que de se
poser des questions on veut des réponses
des réponses des réponses donnez moi des
réponses toujours
et lui il du fait de cette curiosité
était sûrement c'était plutôt ça c est l
inverse
c'était un regard d'enfant regarder le
monde comme un enfant comment enfoncer
quoi un enfant c'est quelqu'un qui est
capable de se délier des connaissances
et du savoir qui n'a d'ailleurs pas
beaucoup mais pour s'éveiller
il part de l'ignorance de
l'émerveillement du monde il est capable
de cela
et du coup dans la question je me pose
c'est de se dire bah regardons comme un
enfant avec des ressources d'avant ce
qu'on est bon mais si on observait
détriment des choses comme un enfant
peut-être à vouloir solliciter des
réponses partout on changerait la donne
on accepte
ce sens des questions qu'on se pose
reste mon dans les bons ce que l'on
cherche à trouver absolument que dans
les questions que l'on se pose à ce
sujet voilà la curiosité de montaigne
elle était à la fois enquêtrice et mon
réseau dutil elle cherchait elle
apprenait à voir elle était la moins
pour un sens elle cherchait - finalement
un but pratique que l'éveil d'un sens
critique
elle se contentait pas de ce qu'elle
savait mais au contraire elle se pose
des questions on omettait contente ça
cette curiosité c'est une publicité
philosophique philosophie qui nous
apprend à regarder le monde
et quand on regarde le monde on a
français se regarder dans le monde le
désir de connaître pour le comment et le
pourquoi des choses le désir finalement
decaux naître avec ses découvertes aussi
en ce sens qu naître c'est là on aime
tous les sens de la philosophie
hobbes observé très bien cela lorsqu'il
écrivait mars qu'il disait on le
léviathan cette famille sera le désir de
connaître le comment et le pourquoi sa
belle curiosité aussi je crois que la
curiosité ne peut pas résidé ou se
limiter à quelques définitions dans un
carnet parce que la curiosité est à
incarner d'ailleurs joué un peu menti
ceci n'est pas vous regarder mais ceci
est à incarner et je vous inviterai à
cela aujourd'hui je dirais surtout je
vous en prie ne signez jamais le
sentiment de curiosité qui vous anime
car la curiosité elle réveille et
éveille chez nous autres grands et bien
d'autres afghans font nous invite au
voyage
et ça je pense que c'est important alors
je terminerai en vous disant l'opération
ça la curiosité c'est sûrement ce désir
et ce plaisir du sens plutôt que tu es à
la rose et oser la curiosité pour demain
et à demain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]